قرابه المليونين و700 الف طفل سوداني دون
الخامس يعانون سوء التغذيه هذا رقم سنوي
لا يتعلق باقتتال الدائري هناك في البلد
هذه الايام لذا تدعم بعض المنظمات
الانسانيه انتاج عجينه الفول السوداني
الغنيه بالبروتين بالدهون بالمغذيات لعلاج
هؤلاء الاطفال المرضى من سوء التغذيه
السودان يعد اكبر الدول الانتاجا للفول
السوداني يصدر نحو اربعه عشر في المئه من
صادرات العالم ككل هذه العجينه ينتجها
مصنع اسمه مصنع سامايل اهم مصانع الاغذيه
في العاصمه الخرطوم تاسس في عام 2011
بشراكه سودانيه فرنسيه زادت طاقته
الانتاجيه من هذه العجينه خلال تسع سنوات
من 1200 الى عشره الاف طن لكنه احترق
بالكامل
وذلك نتيجه المواجهات الدائره في الخرطوم
بين الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع
هذا ما تقوله وسائل اعلام محليه مجموعه
صالح عبد الرحمن يعقوب المالكه للمصنع
قالت المصنع يغطي حاجه السودان والمناطق
المحيطه به وهو المصنع الوحيد من نوعه
الذي يلبي احتياجاته برنامج الغذاء
العالمي ومنظمه اليونيسيف للاطفال والذين
يعانون من سوء التغذيه وخطر المجاعه فقد
عظيم للاطفال السودان المجموعه الفرنسيه
الشريكه في المشروع
تقول المصنع دمر بالكامل اثناء الاقتتال
في الخرطوم ومئات الالاف من السودانيين يا
ترى النحونا في كارثه انسانيه وتزداد
حالتهم سوءا يوما بعد يوم في مواجهه
الانعدام الامن الغذائي المقلق من قبل بدء
الصراع اذا الوضع الغذائي في السودان كان
مقلقا قبل بدايه الصراع كيف علق السوداني
على احتراق المعمل امل تقول تدمير مصنع
شاميل خبر مفجع للوضع الغذائي في السودان
ثلاثه ملايين يعانون من سوء التغذيه
وحوالي 700 الف يعانون من سوء التغذيه
الحاد
توقف ستين في المئه من امداد الاغذيه
العلاجيه الجاهزه المستخدمه في العلاج هو
حكم بالموت المحتم على اطفال السودان احمد
بن عمر يقول لك احمد لا حول ولا قوه الا
بالله مصنع سامي انتهى كل خسائر هندفع
ثمنها نحن كمواطنين والحرب لعينه سعيد قال
في تغريدته ولد تدمير ممنهج للصناعه في
السودان مصنع ساميل من المصانع المتطوره
واللي بتغطي حاجه كبيره في البلد لمنتجات
غالبه ما يتم استيرادها من الخارج عبد
الماجد عبد الحميد
احتراقه مصنع شامل بالخرطوم بحري واحد من
احد عشره مصنعا في العالم متخصصه في انتاج
عجينه غذائيه تستخدم لعلاج سوء التغذيه
عند الاطفال وصل انتاج المصنع لعشره الاف
طن سنويا وكان بصدد رفع الانتاج لعشرين
الف طن وتصدير الفائض تسليم تقول ربنا
يعوضه لكن برضه بنقول داعيه بتركيز كل
الصناعه في الخرطوم هل لو كان المصنع في
شندي او مندي او كوستي مش كان احسن برنامج
الاغذيه العالميه حذر من ان استمرار العنف
في السودان قد يؤدي الى زياده عدد الجوعى
بما يتراوح بين مليونين ومليونين ونصف
المليون شخص ليصل انعدام الامن الغذائي
الحاد الى اكثر من 19 مليون شخص اي حوالي
اربعين في المئه من عدد سكان البلاد
[موسيقى]